bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour un
nouveau 78 politique sur TVfil 78 nous
parlerons tout à l'heure de la campagne
des municipales de voisin le Bretonneux
qui va débuter avec pas moins de qure
listes qui vont s'affronter petit rappel
les élections de l'an dernier qui avait
vu la candidate udi Alexandra rosettil
emporté de 15 voix sétait annulé le mois
dernier par le Conseil d'État sur une
requête de l'ancien maire UMP Alexis
Biet nouveau scrutin programmé donc le
12 avril pour le premier tour pour le
moment je reçois sur ce plateau Carl
olive bonsoir vous êtes le porte-parole
de l'épie ensemble pour les Yvelines le
groupe de la droite pendant cette
campagne des élections départementales
vous étiez aussi vous-même d'ailleurs en
campagne sur le canton de poissie avec
Elodie Sornet vous l'avez emporté avec
plus de 78 % des suffrages on va revenir
sur ce scrutin des départementales qui
vient de s'achever rademaré vague bleue
21 canton sur les 21 sont à droite et au
centre dans le département C inédit
objectif accompli c'était l'objectif
avant avant de de se lancer dans la
bataille écoutez en général quand on
démarre une campagne c'est pour la
gagner hein donc les 20 cantons et les
20 binômes qui se sont présentés dans
ces nouvelles élections dans leur format
à une date qui a changé dans des cantons
qui ont également changé et bien les 21
binômes l'ont emporté aujourd'hui
effectivement vous avez raison le
département est donc composé de de 21
personnes qui font partie de la même
famille politique et je tout de suite
vous posé la question parce que c'est ça
qui inquiétaé beaucoup aussi ne
serait-ce que la gauche il n'y a plus
d'opposition ça veut dire que vous allez
gouverner légiférer en toute
tranquillité où il y aura toujours un
regard critique sur les décisions qui
seront prises au sein de ce groupe
homogène maintenant écoutez on va quand
même pas s'excuser de l'avoir emportter
dans les 21 cantons nos opposants
aujourd'hui donnent des leçons de morale
je vous donne juste un exemple moi je
regrette par exemple d'avoir eu à
affronter le Front National au deème
tour et le Front national à poissie
était au deè tour parce qu'il y a eu des
divisions à gauche et avec les vers et
le Front de Gauche donc les vraies
raisons elles sont là vous savez quand
vous avez gagné vous cherchez des
solutions pour être pour mieux performer
comme l'on dit et certainement pas pour
expliquer qu'il va falloir se chicaner
gratuitement parce qu'on aurait pas
soi-disant d'opposition sur le papier
dans une équipe de sport vous avez par
exemple dans le football vous le savez
11 joueurs qui portent le même maillot
et pourtant il y a 11 caractères qui
peut être parfois différent et ça pose
pas de problème mais on se trompe pas
d'objectif on va détailler ces
différents résultats on va parler de la
division de à gauche d'ailleurs on va
parler du Front national également et
puis évoquer tout de même l'avenir de
cette union de la droite et du centre et
la façon dont vous allez gérer ce
département après ce rappel des
résultats du second tour c'est avec
Catherine
zulato la droite fait le grand schlem
dans les Yvelines Pierre Bédier le
président d'ensemble pour les Yvelines
qui regroupent les élus majoritaires au
conseil départemental l'avait souhaité
dès la fin 2014 en proposant une
alliance avec l'UDI et le modem une
stratégie qui a donc porté ses fruits
l'objectif est atteint je crois que
c'est une belle belle victoire un beau
sujet de satisfaction parce que cet
objectif est atteint d'abord parce qu'on
avait des bons candidats avec des
candidats issus des dernières élections
municipales qui ont fait des scors
remarquables dans leur ville he je pense
à Carl Liv à poissis 78 % dans son
canton c'est aussi le résultat d'un
travail de projet de bons projet qui a
été présenté aux ilinois un bilan qui
était reconnu et puis une stratégie qui
a été celle de l'Union de la Droite du
centre avec l'UDI avec le Modem et même
en allant plus loin avec des divers
droite et des divers gauches la
présidente de la fédération UMP des
ivelines Valérie pcrz dans un communiqué
de presse s félicité des résultats pour
l'ensemble de l'Île-de-France et voit
dans ces élections un formidable
encouragement pour les élections
régionales la gauche qui auparavant
comptait dans ses rang neuf conseillers
généraux ne sera plus représenté dans la
nouvelle Assemblée devenu alors
monocolore sur notre plateau dimanche
soir sa première fédérale appelait à un
travail de terrain il y a un travail à
faire localement parce que on l'a vu sur
les portes à porte les gens vont pas
voter mais ils ont envie qu'on discute
avec eux ils ont ils sont là avec leurs
difficultés et on est là en tant qu'élu
aussi pour répondre à ces difficultés et
puis il y a la réflexion nationale aussi
parce que des gens qui nous expliquent
que ils ne vont pas aller voter parce
que le département ça les intéresse pas
et que globalement leur vie ne leur
convient pas et que il ne voit pas
d'amélioration possible dans les les
temps à venir ça interroge forcément
quand on est au gouvernement le Front
national n'aura pas non plus de
conseillers départementaux si le FN a pu
se maintenir dans huit cantons pour ce
second tour les candidats frontistes ont
tous été battus on avait pas d'objectif
particulier enfin moi je pensais que
c'était un devoir civique si vous voulez
de virer l'équipe Bédier ainsi que c'est
complices de
l'UMP un objectif personnel mais c'était
pas un objectif qui Ava été fixé par le
frond national donc dans les ine on est
dans l'UMPS
totalumps modem
udi tout ce qui existe et contre le
Front national après ces élections place
maintenant au 3è tour l'élection du
président du conseil départemental elle
aura lieu le jeudi 2 avril Pierre Bédier
président sortant annonçait dès dimanche
soir qu'il serait candidat à sa
succession grand chlem donc pour la
droite et ses alliés du centre Carl
olive vous faites partie de ces
différents élus vous l'avez emporté avec
plus de 78 % sur votre canton de poissie
est-ce que c'est une surprise si large
victoire écoutez ça me fait juste
sourire pardonnez-moi mais mais
d'entendre effectivement le tournisque
du Front national avec l'UMPS et les
leçons de morale de la gauche qui
viennent sur le terrain parce que vous
avez raison c'est sur le terrain que ça
se passe depuis le départ euh à poissie
par exemple nous passons notre vie sur
le terrain au municipal on l'a emporté
avec 62,5 % des voix au premier tour et
là nous faisons 82 % et sur le le canton
vous l'avez dit 78 % c'est sur le
terrain que ça se passe mais pas 15
jours des élections moi j'avais deux
binôme dont un je n'ai jamais vu à
poissie en ce qui concerne le Front
National qui a été capable d'envoyer
dans les professions de foie la tête de
candidat du canton de ouille donc oui je
renvoie à Monsieur Chevrier il est
peut-être temps de de d'inciter et bien
les militants à aller sur le terrain
c'est ce que nous avons fait parce parce
que je crois véritablement à la
proximité à la transparence les
administrés sont capables de tout
entendre mais il faut leur expliquer
mais pour leur expliquer il faut être
présent et être présent c'est le terrain
et ça ça sapprend pas dans le
dictionnaire vous avez rappelé les
municipales justement vous l'avez
emporté au municipal à poissi il y a une
certaine dynamique qui a été lancé par
la droite par le Centre également on
peut citer le canton de saint-sir
l'école aussi par exemple Philippe
benasaya qui a fait basculer ce canton à
droite qui a pris la mairie de boisars
auparavant l'année dernière sur les
municipales il y a une certaine voilà
dynamique qui est enclenchée pour la
droite même avec les régionales aussi
qui Dessine moi je crois pouvoir dire
que que Philippe Benassaya à l'instar de
de de d'autres collègues ont
véritablement compris que le
rassemblement était une condition
sineéquanon pour l'emporter là encore
l'UMP l'UDI le modem et puis comme l'a
rappelé le le président Bédier d'autres
familles politiques c'est comme ça que
ça se passe qu'est-ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on on n'est pas confronté à ce
rassemblement et cette union on est dans
la division on est dans la friction
pardonnez-moi de parler de de de poissie
mais sur ce cantonlà que je connais
particulièrement bien j'étais étonné de
voir qu'à l'issue de du premier tour les
Verts qui étaient candidats au premier
tour éliminés la gauche qui était
candidate au premier tour éliminé au
premier tour à la différence du Front
national était content parce qu'ils
avaient compté leur voix voilà et puis
le Front National est au deuxième tour
on se demande pourquoi vous parliez de
cette union ça va être possible de
travailler ensemble justement est-ce que
cette union est suffisamment solide je
vous pose la question parce que bon
l'UDI on sait que c'est un allié de
l'UMP même si quelqu fois il y a des
voies qui se sont élevés mais c'est un
allié presque naturel de l'UMP le modem
c'est un petit peu moins le cas François
berou par le passé qui soutenait
d'ailleurs plutôt François Hollande que
Nicolas Sarkozi sur la dernière
présidentielle aujourd'hui tout ça c'est
derrière aujourd'hui vous travaillez
tous ensemble pardonnez-moi de de de
prendre raccourci mais il y a que les
con qui changent pas d'avis euh là
encore dans dans ma ville depuis mars
2014 nous fonctionnons avec l'UDI et le
modem et on fonctionne très bien c'est
pas une question de personne c'est pas
une question d'étiquette c'est une
question de bon sens c'est une question
effectivement de projet politique moi je
me pose pas la question de savoir si je
vais ou pas m'entendre ou si nos
collègues vont s'entendre ou pas avec
les autres au sein de ce département
c'est qu'est-ce que vous nous voulons
faire de ce département et le façonner
pour nos administ c'est ça qu'ils
attendent ils attendent qu'on les aide
dans les crèches qu'on les aide sur les
résidences pour personnes âgées qu'on
leur améliore leur route qu'on leur
facilite le quotidien qu'on facilite le
développement économique c'est ça qu'ils
attendent vous croyez que sur les
marchés on nous parle de l'UMP du MoDem
de on nous parle pas de ça parce que le
seul mot qui ressort c'est le Front
National et je le comprends par rapport
à cela il faut qu'on vulgarise le
message les compétences c'est ce qu'on a
fait dans l'ensemble des canton la
preuve on l'a emporté et parfois au la
main puisque je vous rappelle que sur
les Chiquet de la victoire on est de 53
pour chez Monsieur Fourgous jusqu'à 78 %
sur le canton de poiss canton de
poissier juste un mot d'ailleurs sur
votre canton de poissie parce qu'il y a
eu un recours qui a été déposé tout de
même ce matin par l'association poissie
info qui a été créé par Richard Bertrand
c'est un ancien élu de poissie et qui
vous accuse notamment d'avoir utilisé
les moyens de la mairie pour pour la
campagne il a un recours donc qui a été
déposé le tribunal administratif devraas
trancher vous avez une réaction par
rapport à ça non ben c'est c'est vous
savez on a un certain nombre de
personnages qui font avec moi ce qu'ils
avaient fait auparavant avec l'ancien
maire um l'ancien maire PS avec qui vous
l'avez rappelé il était adj jou un modem
et puis là il a par exemple appelé à
soutenir le Front national ça
effectivement porté bonheur et ça a été
bénéfique au Front national donc c'est
un confli quoi de personne c'est ça vous
êtes serein avec ce recours écoutez il
faut juste rappeler qu'il y a quand même
une une action en justice au pénal
contre cette personne qui à mon avis
règle ses problèmes privés sur la place
publique et il y a une action en cours
donc voilà effectivement on va s'arrêter
là on revient au succès dans les
ivelines est-ce une victoire aussi de
Nicolas Sarkozi je voulais faire réagir
juste après on va tout tout d'abord
pardon écoutter horore berger elle est
élu d'opposition UMP à manilé elle est
aussi coordinatrice du déploiement du
numéricump c'est une proche de l'ancien
président écoutez c'est une victoire
Nicolas Sarkozi et c'est une victoire
aussi c'est la démonstration que l'Union
ça fonctionne et je pense en effet il va
falloir qu'on retienne cette leçon là
pour la suite le rassemblement qu'on a
réussi à faire dès le premier tour sur
la quasi totalité des cantons à travers
la France et sur la totalité nous des
cantons dans les villes ça a fonctionné
on a une gauche désunie incapable de
s'entendre et on le voit dans dans ce
que vous disiez également c'est-à-dire
que clairement il y a eu un une volonté
é aujourd'hui que les Français donnent
un coup d'arrêt à la politique menée par
François Hollande la réponse c'est
est-ce qu'on va faire ou non entrer des
écologistes au gouvernement j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit ça que les
Français a dit ils ont pas dit qu'ils
voulaient une gauche plus à gauche ils
ont dit qu'ils voulaient arrêter avec
cette politique là et clairement ils ont
donné un mandat à droite à la droite
pour faire différemment donc les
conclusions qui sont tirées par la
gauche me semble quand même très
hasardeux ce soir et nous en tout cas ce
qu'il faut retenir je pense c'est la
nécessité absolue du rassemblement comme
clé de la victoire c'était donc sur
notre plateau dimanche soir en direct
est-ce que vous partagez cet avis c'est
une victoire de Nicolas Sarkozi est-ce
que c'est un bon tremplin aussi pour
2017 c'est la question suivante écoutez
moi j'ai passé ma campagne à parler au
niveau local donc je vais pas changer
maintenant je pense que c'est d'abord la
victoire des 42 candidats qui ont formé
les 2yamique tout même dynamique
nationale évidemment qu'il y a une
dynamique nationale et je suis content
de de constater qu'elle va être
s'enclencher positivement eu égard au
résultats que nous venons d'obtenir
alors c'est la victoire du président de
l'UMP qui est Nicolas Sarkozi c'est la
victoire d'Alain Jupé et de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui souhaitent que
cela change effectivement sur cette
famille politique mais moi je veux pas
faire de de langue de bois c'est
tellement la cacophonie à droite et à
gauche encore aujourd'hui soyons très
humble dans cette victoire continuons
travailler le travail entraî le talent
le talent trraine la réussite et la
prochaine étape avant même les
prochaines élections régionales voire
législatives voir présidentielle pour
2017 c'est déjà l'élection du président
du conseil départemental ce sera ce
jeudi Pierre Bédier qui sera candidat
toutes les voix vont lui revenir être
convaincu en tout cas moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'effectivement le
président Bédier s'il se représente euh
soit effectivement le prochain président
du conseil départemental et surtout
qu'il donne les moyens à ses à ses
conseillers de pouvoir porter les
projets que nous avons présentés au
cours de de cette campagne c'est ça le
plus important ces différents projets je
vais vous poser les questions dessus
justement dans un instant mais juste une
parenthèse vous parlez de l'Union depuis
tout à l'heure à la fin de cette édition
du 78 politique nous reviendrons sur la
situation à voisin lebretonneux il y a
des élections municipales qui vont être
organisées à à nouveau le Conseil d'État
a invalidé le scrutin de l'année
dernière le maire UMP qui a été battu
par son ancien adjointe udi qui a déposé
donc un recours il y a une quinzaine de
voix d'écart entre les deux candidats
nouvelle élection 12 avril premer tour
ça fait un peu désordre même s'il y a
pas d'investiture je vais tout de même
le préciser parce que Valérie pcres la
responsable départemental l'a dit encore
aujourd'hui il n'y aura ni investiture
de la part de l'UMP ni de l'UDI dans ce
conflit qui se règlera sur le terrain et
dans les urnes en tout cas malgré tout
c'est embarrassant euh non je pense pas
que ce soit embarrassant ce qu'il faut
juste constater c'est quand même très
dommage et dommageable que ces élections
ont lieu le 12 avril alors qu'on vient
d'avoir des élections le 22 et le 29
mars tout simplement si on pouvait
éviter et aller dans les économies de
doners public c'est important je prends
juste le cas sur la ville de de de
poissi on est après de de plus de 90000
€ quand même sur les dépenses à
l'échelle du pays c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent si on pouvait
mutualiser les élections on ferait
beaucoup d'économie et c'est à mon sens
pas un gros effort à faire pour revenir
sur la question que POS question
division UMP écoutez je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans une équipe il y a des
caractères différents alors que le
meilleur gagne il y a pas eu
d'investiture de donné le meilleur sera
celui qui aura fait la meilleure
campagne et que ce soit le candidat
sortant ou son prédécesseur de toute
façon il sera accueilli et je l'espère
et j'espère qu'il l'emportera quel que
soit effectivement l'UMP ou l'UDI enfin
de cette famille politique et il seront
accueilli les bras grands ouverts
effectivement dans la future assiette
départementale donc vivement que cette
parenthèse soit refermée non pas
vivement il faut que à chaque jour
suffit à peine il faut laisser le temps
effectivement aux candidats d'aller
expliquer leur projet leur projet
municipal pour voisin le Bretonneux et à
l'issue de de ce projet il y aura une
entrée ou pas au conseil départemental
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure le canton
de trappe a aussi basculé avec à peu
près 53 % pour le duo Jean-Michel
fourgousse Anne Capion on revient sur le
basculement de ce bastion historique de
la gauche avec ce reportage Alain ajage
maire communiste de la verrière Janine
Marie conseillère départementale
sortante ne peuvent que constater
l'ampleur de la vague bleue leur binôme
ne totalise que 46,9 % des suffrages
exprimés insuffisant pour conserver le
canton de trappe un bastion de la gauche
qui couvre également la verrière et
hlencour non je suis triste pour les
Trappistes triste pour les verrièrois
mais triste aussi pour la partie des
élan courtois qui ne soutenait pas
monsieur Fourgous parce ça veut dire
qu'effectivement deux villes sont
éliminés de la représentation
départementale et euh monsieur euh
Fourgous et Madame capio dlancours vont
représenter nos trois communes
l'abstention aura joué un rôle majeur
lors du second tour dans ce canton pour
Janine Marie les décisions du
gouvernement ces dernières années qui
ont entraîné une déception d'une partie
de la population explique un manque de
motivation pour se rendre aux urnes je
pense que les gens justement parce
qu'ils sont de trappe et qui sont en
très grande souffrance moi je vois ça
tous les jours en tant qu'adjointe au
maire à la politique familiale je sais
quelle est leur souffrance et je
comprends je comprends leur désespoir et
peut-être même leur vote moi je suis
républicain et et démocrate et quand
quand je vois que même dans dans dans ce
canton il y a pas il y a pas
mobilisation des habitants de façon
forte je suis je ne suis pas satisfait
ça veut dire que le le choix est fait
par que 30 % des personnes qui qui ont
voté mais voilà ça ne me plaît pas
Jean-Michel Fourgous maire UMP
d'élancour Anne capioot première
adjointe à l'éducation dans cette même
ville sont donc élu avec un peu plus de
53 %. premièrement c'est pas un coup
d'état c'est c'est c'est c'est les votes
c'est un vote démocratique d'abord bon
les Français enfin les les Linois l'ont
voulu hein même moi j'étais étonné parce
que j'ai vu les scores moi j'ai vu que
dans des des bureaux ici j'ai fait 70 %
j'ai jamais fait 70 % dans bure de vote
dans ma vie moi donc on sent bien quand
même qu'il y a il y a un rejet quand
même du socialisme abstention division
de la gauche reporte des voix du Front
national autant de facteurs qui ont joué
dans cette entre de tour et cette
défaite de la gauche est aussi un revers
pour Benoît amont le député socialiste
conseiller municipal à trappe qui n'a
pas réussi à contenir l'Union de la
Droite et lui qui pourtant a largement
contesté les choix du gouvernement c'est
dernier mois ce bastion de la gauche a
donc basculé également à droite avec les
intercommunalités les municipalités
nombreuses à être passées à droite
aujourd'hui le Conseil départemental
entièrement à droite maintenant vous
allez pouvoir mener tous les projets que
vous souhaitez développer un mot sur sur
ce qu'on vient de voir parce que
effectivement monsieur aage et Madame
Marie sont deux candidats à la fois
responsables et efficaces ce sont deux
très bons candidats et je tiens je tiens
à le dire une Marie qui est sortante he
qui a siégé jusqu' pr que je connais
très bien qui qui a fait un très bon
travail au au sein de l'assiette
départementale et je regrette qu'elle
soit pas là je suis ravi pour
Jean-Michel Fourgous évidemment mais
pour Jean-Michel Fourgous et puis pour
capio bien sûr mais voilà je on perd on
perd en tout cas une une collègue très
efficace à laass départementale c'est la
désunion c'est la désunion mais pour
autant je constate quand même qu'il y
avait un duel républicain et ça il faut
s'en féliciter que vous n'avez pas eu à
poissi comme vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs on va venir sur le
Front national dans dans quelques
instants sur ces projets que vous allez
mener aujourd'hui ça va faciliter le
travail les maie principalement à droite
le Conseil départemental les interco
aussi comme à 50 ans neline à droite
aujourd'hui il faut travailler en
stratégie d'équipe et on peut pas
réussir les projets le développement
économique si on n'est pas dans une
stratégie d'équipe et de complémentarité
alors il faudra porter ces projets le
salut notamment c'est le développement
économique l'idée de créer par exemple
une agence d'insertion départementale
c'est une très belle idée l'idée
effectivement que les bénéficiaires du
RSA puissent également apporter leur
contribution au service de de la
collectivité c'est un projet sur lequel
il faut se battre avec l'agence
d'insertion départementale c'est une des
solutions je pourrais également vous
citer l'auto-école solidaire avec la
possibilité pour des jeunes qui n'en ont
pas la possibilité aujourd'hui de
pouvoir et bien avec cette école cette
auto-école solidaire passer leur permis
à moindre coût et puis pouvoir
bénéficier ensuite du véhicule pour
aller pour aller travailler parce qu'on
peut en dire ce qu'on en veut mais
aujourd'hui un jeune qui démarre dans la
vie professionnelle sans véhicule c'est
bien plus compliqué Carl olive pour
l'UMP l'Union de la Droite vous
réagissez aux différents résultats C
départemental le second tour qui a donc
livré son verdict et le Front National
qui a été évoqué d'ailleurs depuis tout
à l'heure vous avez rencontré à poissie
en frontal he lors du du second tour je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur une
déclaration de Nicolas Boer c'est le
responsable Front national dans la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines il était
candidat lui-même sur le canton de
trappe est battu dès le premier tour
écoutez c'était sur ce plateau également
je vis revenir je vrais revenir une
seconde sur ou sur le département des
Yvelines moi j'étais en contact
évidemment avec les résultats sur sur
mante la jolie notamment
il faut savoir que sur quelques bureaux
de vote du valfouré monsieur Bédier fait
près de 95 % des voix donc je pense que
ce sont des scores qui sont dignes d'une
république bananière et quand on a un
président du conseil départemental comme
ça il y a vraiment de quoi s'inquiéter
moi j'aimerais qu'on fasse qu' a des
éclaircissements qui soi apporter un
appel sur le scrutin sur les résultats
du côté de mon bah je pense
quetional résultats encore généraux mais
je peux vous dire que comm vous pointez
du doigt certains chiffres estce que ce
sont des chiffres sur lesquels vous
pourriez contester le résultat ben je
pense pas qu'on va contester le le
résultat ce qu'on conteste c'est
qu'effectivement je vois que le candidat
du Front national fait 25 voix sur 525
suffrages exprimés dans des dans un
bureau de vote du valfouré c'est
absolument
extraordinaire le Front National qui
aimit des des doutes sur la véracité de
de ce scrutin sur ce que les urnes ont
livré bah écoutez moi par exemple
à poissille j'ai un candidat du Front
national qui nous demandait où était
l'hôtel de ville de carrière sous
poissille on était à poissille donc
quand on a des candidats fantôme on a ce
qu'on mérite c'est la seule réponse que
vous aurez à faire pour vous parce queon
sait que le conflit a été assez rude
entre cyil na et Pierre Bédier sur ce
scrutin départemental oui mais vous
savez pendant que ce type de de
personnes tapent fling comme Philippe
Noiret dans le vieux fusi sur ses
adversaires d'autres sont sur le terrain
aller parler aux électeurs et c'est ce
qu'ils attendent moi j'ai absolument pas
parlé de mes adversaires je vais pas
commencer aujourd'hui C je rappelle qui
tout de même le maire de M la ville pour
candidat fantôme il est tout de même
implanté il a tout de même une
légitimité aussi il a il a il a emporté
le scrutin municipal bah a priori ça pas
l'air de lui sourir il sera pas il sera
pas présent sur laassette départemental
et je m'en réjouis sur les résultats du
Front national on écoute Pierre Bédier
justement il parle d'un cri de colère à
entendre les électeurs sont bien
conscients qu'après le criit de colère
du premier tour et qu'il nous faut
entendre après ce CR de colère ben il
faut être dans la réalité et le Front
national n'est pas dans la réalité euh
ce sont des élucubrations bien souvent
de gauche enfin d'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite on ne sait plus où ils
sont secret de colère il doit quand même
nous interpeller et ça fera partie
d'ailleurs de maisage j'en conserve
l'exclusivité au conseillers
départementaux jeudi prochain ça fera
partie de de mon discours d'investiture
parce que nous ne pouvons pas ignorer ce
crit de colère on ne peut pas ignorer ce
crit de colère vous les avez entendu ces
électeurs qui ont voté Front national
sur votre canton dans votre ville aussi
écoutez moi je pars du principe que
l'élu républicain quel qu'il soit doit
commencer par appliquer la règle et ne
pas l'interpréter quand vous appliquez
la règle on est plutôt récompensé c'est
ce que je fais à poissie depuis 2014 et
je note et je note qu'aujourd'hui au
résultat des élections notamment sur
poissi le Front National est au moins 10
points derrière l'ensemble des communes
au premier tour mais il a tout de même
fait des voix donc ces électeurs vous
les entendez mais attendez à l'échelle à
l'échelle du pays quand vous faites 15
points quand d'autres arrivent à faire
40 % et parfois la majorité c'est aussi
que pour être dans le vrai il faut
effectivement être dans un rappel des
règles systématique et aujourd'hui quand
on interprète les règles ça exaspère ça
exaspère donc il faut rappeler les
règles une fois qu'on a rappelé les
règles on est dans le jeu on est en
dehors du jeu et moi je rappelle à mes
collègues de droite républicaine que de
temps en temps il serait bon de rappeler
les règles et d'appliquer la règle et de
pas l'interpréter parce que
l'interpréter c'est une porte ouverte
totale à l'interprétation et on peut
faire tout est ce qu'on et ce qu'on veut
et donc on attise on attise l'éclivage
et la réponse c'est celle que notamment
manth a obtenu à mante la ville en mars
2014 merci Carl olive d'être venu sur ce
plateau conseiller départemental sur
poissie vous étiez également le
porte-parole de l'épie du groupe
majoritaire pendant cette campagne on va
continuer à évoquer les départementales
avec la gauche qui parle de
rassemblement rassemblement et qui sera
tout de même assez difficile on a senti
la division au plus haut sommet de
l'État sur cette question et même
beaucoup plus bas sur le terrain local
le combat au sein de la gauche lors des
départementales va forcément laisser des
cicatrices exemple avec Jean-Philippe
met conseiller général sortant
socialiste il a perdu son poste sur le
canton de saint-cier l'école il ne
digère pas franchement l'attitude de ses
anciens alliés d'Europe Écologie et du
Front de gauche lors de l'entre de tour
écoutez Europe Écologie Les Verts le
Front de Gauche n'a pas appelé à voter
pour nous mais n'a pas appelé à voter
non plus pour les socialistes dans
d'autres canton nul n'est propriétaire
de son électorat mais quand même je
trouve qu'ils ont là enfin une grande
règle à gauche historique et le
désistement républicain et qu'on pense
les princip concernés c'était lors de
notre soirée électorale du second tour
sur TV film morceau choisi de deux
déclarations celle d'É Germain vedreen
candidate au premier tour pour le Front
de gauche sur le canton de montinil
Bretonneux et puis également d'in
premolis c'est le coresponsable sur 50
ans neline d'urope Écologie Les Verts il
n'y a jamais eu de demande d'union de la
part du Parti socialiste sur le canton
et d'ailleurs le Parti socialiste sera
incapable de produire le moindre écrit
dans ce sens le Parti socialiste
souhaitait partir seul au premier tour
parce qu'il pensait pouvoir conserver ce
canton de notre côté non plus il n'y
avait pas de volonté d'union on n'est
pas dans un calcul finalement la
politicien mais nous sommes en désaccord
sur un certain nombre de points au
niveau des lignes départementales et
nationales aujourd'hui entre les
socialistes et puis le Front de gauche
et puis le socialiste et puis et puis
Europe Écologie Les ver il y a quand
même un cvage aujourd'hui ce clivage
c'est c'est c'est la la politique très
libérale qui qui est appliqué
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement et qui
ne nous convient pas du tout donc là il
faudrait beaucoup de remaniments
peut-être même un changement de Premier
ministre pour
que je je ne suis pas dans secret des
dieux je ne suis jamais que le reste
responsable du groupe local de
Saint-Quentin livline donc je ne peux
pas parler au nom du d'Ur cololog les
ver je dis simplement mon sentiment et
puis la lecture de tous les mails que je
reçois tous les jours actuellement je ne
pense pas que nous rentrerion comme ça
sans sans sans conditions et en même
temps manuel Val se dit qu'il resterait
au gouvernement et François hand avait
dit qu'il ne changerait ni de politique
ni de Premier ministre ça que c'est pour
ça que je crois que la situation un peu
bloqué voilà voilà ce qu'on peut dire
sur les élections départemental et puis
concernant les élections municipales
aussi de voisin le bretonne le premier
tour ce sera le 12 avril vous pourrez
bien évidemment suivre tout ça sur TVfil
78 dans les prochains jours et pour le
reportage complet sur les différentes
listes qui vont se présenter face aux
électeurs vcinois et les électeurs
vcinoises rendez-vous sur les électrices
vcinoises rendez-vous sur notre site
internet dès à présent pour découvrir ce
reportage de la rédaction c'est la fin
de cette édition du 78 politique la
semaine prochaine mardi 18h30 ce sera le
retour du 78 société pour de nouveaux
débats 78 politique le prochain ce sera
dans un mois excellente
soirée